ici à sancerre je vais vous raconter une
histoire qui dure depuis 14 générations
laurent reverdit a reçu de son
grand-père à savoir faire en plein coeur
des photos de son ca vous avez tout
savoir tout comprendre sur l'origine
d'un breuvage à forte personnalité qui a
su séduire bien au delà du centre val de
loire de la france de l'europe et même
du monde même de lattes et a même sur
mars on ira sur marsura du sancerre sera
grâce à laurent enfin loin non à le
point g concerts partout ils sont trop
fortes et les rues verdict le feu dix
mois
messieurs dames bonjour jean dominique
laurent on est d'accord on est sur la 14
ème génération exactement de père en
fils de père en fils est ce que tu as
des frères et soeurs oui j'ai une soeur
parisienne mais dans la famille à
l'origine c'était un peu les garçons qui
prenait la succession d'accord au tout
petit mon père m'emmenait avec lui dans
ces villes par contre comment est-ce que
tu mens bel et bien vous allez faire un
petit tour dans les caves faire une
petite dégustation ont confié on ira
faire le tour des dvi allez je vous suis
maître l'on a laissé les alizés
elle est forte en avait franchement les
fortins
les cas
qui est ce monsieur là c'est saint
vincent c'est notre saint patron nous le
célébrons chaque 22 janvier pour qu'il
protège nos vins nouveaux mie
rituellement c'est très très important
pour nous bon d'accord mains sales usa
dassault
et il répond et toi tu diras tu trouves
ça normal c'est spirituel vous avez des
pouvoirs magiques les reverdy et
pourquoi on l'aimé on fut comme ça on va
laisser respirer les vins à travers le
chêne et
donnez la subtilité au vin
là tu vas te rends tu compte on est un
peu sur les vanilles on est sur les
jolies notes boisées côté raisins
étaient toujours présents et donc du
coup c'est quand les bonbons c'est en
septembre et d'ailleurs on va aller
faire un tour dans les vignes c'est un
endroit où on a plein d'histoires de
famille où on a commencé à travailler
avec les générations antérieures tu
parles de génération antérieure mais bon
je vais poser une question la première
fois première fois devant c'était dans
les vignes vue sur évidemment
tout savoir
vous avez tous comprend alors là je veux
tout savoir didon je m'attendais quand
même pas à des questions comme ceux
là on est sur les vrais caillotte on
aperçoit que des cailloux blancs et ça
c'est le secret du fruité de notre
sincère bienvenue dans la tour
c'est ici que de la ramener la première
fois chez sur les premières conquêtes là
tous les jeunes du village sont pas
séparés car les filous les filous
ces deux-là vu ça ici c'est quand même
un endroit que tu as découvert avec ton
grand père dès l'âge de 3 c'est quoi ces
commensacq lhc les revers dizaine
d'années on imprègne un petit peu le
tranquillement leur métier toutes les
grandes familles n'arrivent pas à
maintenir une telle cohésion tu retombes
de génération c'est quoi votre secret
pour savoir où on va il faut savoir d'où
on vient les exploitations familiales
sancerroise reste les pieds sur terre a
essayé de maîtriser un petit peu tout la
culture de la vigne l'évolution du vin
et les marchés à venir en face bon
laurent me va tout ça on sait que tu es
fan forcément mais tout aussi fan de la
deûle agence tous risques effectivement
j'adore qu'un plan se déroule sans
accroc à la
souris style allez on part en mission
allez on y va
bruno godard
après moi j'ai encore dans l' agence
tous risques 14e génération il faut
penser à la transmission la suite tiens
justement j'ai sans braquer la la
succession et là nous avons trois
enfants ensemble dans ce grand garçon de
23 ans d'accord une une fille de 12 ans
qui ont aussi très motivé pour reprendre
le donner donc là peut-être y aura une
fille et un garçon qui vont prendre la
suite c'est possible ils sont toujours
en avance sur leur temps toujours monde
et inferno verdict toujours en beauté